so der einreise stoppt in den usa heute
glaube ich gerechtfertigt mit einem
erfundenen massaker von drums beraterin
dieser ein reisestopp hat zu chaos an
den flughäfen geführt hat sich das
inzwischen beruhigt wir schalten live zu
ulrich von heesen für uns am new yorker
jfk ulrich hersteller immer noch chaos
naja die einreise in die usa war schon
immer etwas nervig aber jetzt kriegen
die beamten hier zusätzlich
unfreundlichkeit kurse da lernen wie man
zum beispiel mit einer deutschen roma
umgehen versehentliche kopftuch auf
gelassen hat selber schuld der alte was
läuft sie auch um wege aus der mascus es
wird immer komplizierter jeden tag neue
einreise regeln von tram leute aus
bestimmten ländern dürfen nicht rein typ
mit bart dürfen natürlich nicht rein
du bist nicht du hebst da und seien
heute dürfen auch keine rothaarigen
frauen mehr einreisen
warum das denn ja meint das sind hexen
entspricht auch meiner eigenen erfahrung
[Musik]
so und warum darf der jetzt rein hatte
es okay
er ist aus saudi arabia
das sind zwar auch muslime aber reiche
russen
[Applaus]
ausgenommen sind übrigens auch alle
länder in dem trump hotels hat dass er
kein rassist verstehe aber sie konnten
offensichtlich problemlos einreisen
klar zu mir waren die hier super nett
ich bin ja schon mal selter und habe zum
glück noch meinen alten aria nachweis
was ich immer sage nie was wegschmeißen
eines tages ist kann es wieder gebraucht
der trump ist ein macher welke wenn er
sagt grenze dich dann ist grenze dicht
können wir deutschen uns mal eine
scheibe von abschneiden
jetzt werden zb bei uns die chance
gewesen die idioten aus dem rtl
dschungel nicht mehr zurück ins land zu
lassen
aber wir sind zu weichen ja was denn
jetzt wo hast du scheiße da versucht
schon wieder ein kind einzureichen nein
ja ja brandgefährlich die bratzel
ja ja ja ruhig nochmal kasan ja dann
zählt er das nie wirklich richtig von
herzen viel lang
logisch wir uns auf der wir lassen
nichts machen
libyen